hey everybody it's Mike from overflows
and I hope everyone's doing well and
welcome to today's video you know today
is uh January 5th it is Thursday
tomorrow we got the non-farm payroll
number coming out
um you know we'll see what uh fireworks
that brings now
um before I begin I'll be sure to
subscribe to the channel and like the
video if you get something out of it
what are we talking about today is using
a Delta footprint to spot absorption and
the reason why I want to bring this up
is because you know I've gotten a few
emails uh over the last week or you know
over you know basically over the
Christmas break I'm asking you know how
can you see absorption because you know
absorption is something that you know
it's a term that gets thrown around a
lot and
when you're using a footprint chart in
my opinion the easiest way to see it is
by using a Delta footprint now what I
have up here on my screen is your normal
bid ask footprint right you're seeing
the volume traded on the bid the volume
traded on the offer now
at a price level right there's generally
going to be something traded on the bid
something traded on the offer and when
we're looking at a normal volume
footprint we're generally looking at how
it's transacting in the two-way auction
now with a Delta footprint there's two
types there's a diagonal Delta and
there's a horizontal Delta horizontal
Delta is at the price right 38 49.75 165
traded on the bid 169 traded on the
offer when I use a normal Delta
footprint I am taking the difference
between 165 and 169 and it'll show up as
a reading of four positive Delta now for
example the next price level
38 49 and three quarters it's 240 traded
on the bid 108 traded on the offer so in
this case the Delta would be minus 132
and it would show up on the bid side now
the diagonal Delta will show it to you
in the two-way auction right when the
market is the difference between the bid
and the offer and when I'm looking for
absorption on a footprint chart I'm
looking at the price where was the
volume traded at that price was it
traded on the bid was it traded on the
offer then the next thing I'm looking
for is the magnitude you know was it
strong volume or or was it just normal
volume or or even small volume
and really what I'm looking for when I'm
looking at the Delta footprint is I'm
looking for those pockets of big volume
because that often represents strong
resting liquidity at the market right
you hear the terms uh taking liquidity
providing liquidity right when someone
buys at the market they are removing
liquidity from the market
if there's if you're going in and you
are working a limit order you know
whether for one contract or 100
contracts you are providing liquidity
into the market so let's uh go switch
this to a Delta footprint chart right
now this is your normal bid ask
footprint and you know most order flow
software will allow you to have
different types of footprints and again
if if your footprint doesn't have it you
should probably get a footprint that has
some flexibility to add to to change it
you know my order flow is Trader we got
bid ask we've got Delta we've got volume
we've got diagonal delta type of
footprint so I'll change this to a Delta
footprint now again for this video today
I'm using an e-mini one minute chart you
know most people
like to look at e-minis most people use
a time-based chart now I know a lot of
people also use range based charts but
you know sort of keep it uh simple we'll
just use a simple time based chart and
let's take a look at what I'm looking at
so when you're looking at the Delta
footprint again remember it's the
horizontal
bid and offer so you're seeing what
traded on the bid at a price 38.50 and
the volume traded on the offer at 38.50
I'm not using the diagonal Delta
okay so I'll just give it a second to
come up here you know today we had
actually a quite a bit of movement they
started out really
I don't say slow but you know we opened
up and we we're at our lows of the day
when cash opened then you know once cash
opened we pushed down and started making
new lows then we just sort of went I I
hate to say sideways because our range
you know we're looking at around 38 23
right here up to around 38.50 for most
of the morning okay so what I'm looking
at right if I'm looking at a Delta
footprint
for absorption is now I'm not saying you
know during the course of the trading
day you're always flipping your charts
back and forth now keep it at you know
screens are inexpensive now and if
you're looking at a footprint you're a
day trader and it's in your best
interest to add another screen and just
keep a Delta footprint up there for
finding something that can give you an
insight into the market that
you probably wouldn't have noticed if
you're just looking at a normal bid ask
footprint you know I I see people always
say well you know screens are you know
you got a lot of screens because you're
you're compensating for something no you
know you're just trying to find an edge
right I've got multiple screens I got
big monitors and I break up my screens
in my Monitor I've got you know four
charts on one monitor because I got a 43
inch couple of 43 inch monitors so I'm
looking at a lot of things right because
you know who knows you might find that
one little thing that's going to give
you an insight into the market you might
have overlooked
so what I'm really looking for right now
this is a horizontal Delta just a normal
Delta footprint okay and as we're going
into the lows right as this is
um what you're sort of expecting to see
right you're seeing the volume being
transacted on the bid side right because
there's we're coming into liquidity
right everyone's got orders that are
resting in there I'm sort of looking for
these areas where there's big liquidity
okay you know here's 363. so as we're
coming down I'm not surprised to see
um you know the volume at the bottom of
the bars here you know all on the mid
side all on the mid side all on the mid
side that's what you expect to see it's
when I start seeing the market you know
move away from lows and then start
coming back down and testing areas is
really what I'm looking for so for
example this bar right here at 907
this is the type of bar that I like to
see where you know we rallied up from
the low of 23 and what was it 23 and a
half got all the way up to 40. we're
coming up in here sort of a swing High
we're running into you know a couple of
bars with resting liquidity we come back
you know earlier we came up here you
know 111 121 come off a little bit work
our way back up 143 166 189 104 107.
come off come back up I still see some
liquidity there and then we come back
down then this little tiny bar here that
looks so inconsequential this is the
type of bar that I like where
basically from the midpoint below you
have the volume on the bid side the
midpoint above all the volume on the
offer side so what's what's it telling
me well it's telling me this Market is
coming down and it's coming down into
liquidity
all right it's coming down it's
aggressive sellers are selling it but
it's being met with some nice passive
buyers in the market
um and then once the market once you
know I'll say once Traders realize
there's liquidity there but it's
absorbing whatever selling is taking
place then what you see on the way back
up is just all the offer is getting
lifted okay now people often will save
me Mike well yeah you know shouldn't you
just look for those bars where it's just
all the offers are being lifted like
this yeah I mean that's what you expect
to see right when a market is trading
off right I mean obviously the offers
are being lifted the market is going up
that's nice to see bars with you know
majority of the offers but that's what a
green bar is going to look like what I
want to see is where the market came
into an area of liquidity and that
liquidity just soaked up it absorbed all
that selling that was taking place you
know and not just like here where it's
just three price levels at the bottom
because at the bottom of green bars
you're looking for that liquidity but
when it's about half of the bar
and it's a green candle it's coming down
into that liquidity that's telling me
something just as you know later
um or was it
when we got up to where was that price
area I mean these are nice but these are
still green candles
um still a little wary of it
but I'll talk about that in a second but
let's get to that point
um it was around 12 something
we started see a little bit of movement
here okay so now it's we're sort of
coming up into this area up in here
right we got all the way up to 38.50
even so we rallied up right we had this
nice little movement you know this nice
big bar up
um we're coming up
we ran into some liquidity up here came
off a little bit
um next bar sort of comes up towards it
not necessarily strong volumes then
starts coming off and then we make
another run we finally get right up to
38.50 but on this move here right that
to me this was very telling
you got some strong volumes in here
right you got the 121 the 138 186 193 75
now again remember this is Delta this is
the difference between the volume that
traded on the bid the volume that traded
on the offer and I just I know just by
looking at the bars when I'm seeing this
type of volume sort of at the tops of
red candles that's telling me that you
know there's strong liquidity up there
as opposed to just you know 2 1 40 50.
you know here with some strong liquidity
as well you know the 105 130 134
Market didn't really come off of that
here it sort of came off a little bit
better
um you know I'd still be looking to sell
this if this next bar was starting to
break and head a bit lower now what I
liked about this bar as well
was again
once you ran into that liquidity what
you had is everyone turned sellers here
right you see just it's all on the mid
side the aggressive selling took over in
this case you know the market just went
inside inside for a little bit
um one bar two bars and then third bar
finally it started to break down and
then it was just slowly you know
grinding down lower
um from you know this is that's what 45
in level 45 and a quarter
um you know where you get down into the
30s it was a little bit more of a slower
grind you know a bit later it did break
down you know again here and then here
um we did run up into this you know
borrow about 150
but we came up here tested it and again
you could sort of see that liquidity
taking place there right the 205 the
177. now
people asking what about the volume on
the bid side right as the market is
going up well yeah normally this would
be a nice bullish bar right if this bar
was positioned lower in the move right
and I'm seeing this big
negative Delta the minus 432 the minus
249 at much lower prices to me that
would be very bullish right but again
it's coming up after you move from 38
you know 38 all the way up to 38.50
um so I'm getting that it's just it just
sort of gives that impression of you
know it's coming in after a move people
are sort of fomo into the market oh
we're breaking out because we broke out
above you know the 50 Area we're going
higher you know people are tripping over
themselves trying to get long but
they're running into resting liquidity
here Market comes off and then again it
just struggles to come back up every
time it sort of starts poking back up
around the 50 51 area it runs into some
liquidity here here and then the market
sells off
so you know that's the way that I use
Delta Footprints now you know there's
certain setups that I like to look for
in
um the delta
and there was one uh where was it here I
just glossed over really quick
um
yeah it's going back a little bit
further
but things that I like to see in the
Deltas is something like this now again
I don't really like to get short off of
green candles right because oftentimes
there's a reason why it's green now when
you're obviously trading on a minute
based chart you know the chart just
closes after 60 seconds if you're on a
one minute chart so sometimes you know
you get these green candles even though
they're small I do know the market did
run up into some liquidity up in here
here as well in the next minute this
work out interesting because this bar
this is a red candle is what we call a
Delta tail where it has this one
positive Delta on top and then just all
the bids getting hit here right you can
see the minus 18 minus 24 minus 144
minus 34 minus 93 63 minus 14 all on the
bid side so I ran the market ran up into
liquidity right up in here right you can
just see so just a wall of liquidity
here
comes off runs back up more liquidity
Bar opens up trades a little bit here
and then it's just all getting hit right
in this bar then this bar majority of
the volume that's taking place
or I'll say the majority of the volume
but majority of the aggressive trading
right because this is a Delta footprint
it's not a regular footprint is taking
place on the bid side so all here
majority here
what are you expecting right
before you had very strong aggressive
buying strong aggressive buying now
you're starting to see strong aggressive
selling obviously the Deltas are
negative and again you know looking at
this move up if you were to take into
account the Deltas
um you know here's positive 272 or 667
351 1 340 112.
okay so the market is going up Deltas
are getting weaker right 600 350 340 112
obviously negative more negative that's
your sign to get short right you're not
looking for this you shouldn't be
looking for this Market to
um all of a sudden turn around and start
rallying because now you're seeing all
that aggressive selling coming in and
the market drops about uh a quick 10
points over the next
five six minutes all right so you know
that's how a Delta footprint can help
you spot signs of absorption but more
importantly it's not just spotting the
signs of absorption as you see here but
it's also picking up what you want to
see after the absorption is
the bids or the offer you know if it's
absorption at a high after a move up
once you see that absorption you want to
see the market turn sellers you want to
see the aggressive sellers coming in
hitting those bids and the market to
drop just as if you're at the low or a
low of the day you're looking for that
sign of absorption but not only that you
want to see that aggressive buying come
in you want to see all the offers
getting lifted right you don't want to
be seen
um you know two-way trade going back and
forth because for the move to be a quick
clean move Swift one you want to see
that aggressive trading coming in and
just whack all as many bids as possible
giving you that sign that you know what
this Market's about to move and you know
in this case down
so anyway I hope you guys enjoyed this
video I sort of took a a long way to get
to the point but um you know sometimes I
I find myself tripping over my words so
anyway I hope you guys appreciate this
video be sure to like And subscribe the
channel and I'll catch you guys on the
next video bye bye